12/10 témoins l'appareil discret parce
que finalement donc celui qui a dit
didier cramer on ne sait pas qui c'est
là on jamais su ce que vous lui disiez
s'il y en a qui ont cherché un livret
jeu les gens lui seul élève très mal
ouais sincèrement on est donc là quoi
voulu annoncer que vous partez de
trouver bourru là têtus que vous non une
discussion oui autour de ce sujet là
mais bon certainement pas j'avais pas
annoncé après will also be there bah oui
ça aurait été trop facile puis non je
n'ai pas envie je voulais vous profitez
ce moment de bonheur avec mes camarades
et puis savourait surtout cette vision
là j'ai vraiment savouré parce que je
savais c'est énorme
à la fin du coup de sifflet final que
c'était certainement un dernier très
grand match on avait l'équipe nationale
alors bon vous portez à valence l'a donc
problème physique évidemment vous preuve
de confiance non
avec hector cuper là ils préfèrent par
ruben baraja non comme non mais ça a été
lié il m'a fait confiance dès le départ
j'ai très bien débuté en moins et demi
et puis j'ai eu une première blessure
aux adducteurs en moi je reviens ils
meurent fait jouer je me robles là j'en
prends pour deux mois ouais donc j'ai
été absent pendant trois mois
l'équipe a bien tourné et puis j'ai eu
du mal à revenir et il ya eu d'autres
joueurs qui ont joué qui aurait été bon
il faut l'accepter aussi mais c'est
surtout ma blessure qui m'a empêché
d'être compétitif et j'ai recommencé à
jouer et ça lâche et encore un peu
derrière la cuisse d'un club alors dites
moi j'ai encore deux ans de contrat
là-bas
oui je vais rester deux ans quand là bas
c'est possible tout dépend pour la
première fois je
g
introduit dans mon esprit la notion de
plaisir or aux jeux et donc j'ai pas
j'ai deux ans il me reste deux ans à
jouer et donc j'ai envie de prendre du
plaisir de jouer et donc si c'est pour
rester à valence est être assis comme ce
soir ça m'intéresse pas beaucoup donc on
verra comment ça se passait en chantier
s'annonce ici alors on se dit si rage
royal sur les hyènes niveau enseignement
c'est parce qu'il en soit si on fait de
l'argent pour le troncage la fin de vos
jours là non oui c'est bien payé le foot
la non la footballeur était prisé au
niveau médiatique married l'arrêt de la
chasse aux coûts c'est vrai vous avez
pas fait dans la bouse et très sec votre
femme vous je suis très bien là oui il
me convient et or avec moi je suis un
excellent donc je n'avais pas fait dans
la benne qui non mais je moi jules
avantage peut-être par rapport à
d'autres footballeur d'avoir une vie
avant cette victoire en coupe du monde
donc bon je suis pas passé d'une extrême
à l'autre
ça a été plus difficile pour certains
joueurs qui sont passés de d'une période
où il n'était pas très connu à être des
stars bien maintenant
didier deschamps eux quand je vais jouer
avec la juve
vous avez été entendu par un juge
d'instruction turinois ont des problèmes
d'usagé de dopage maison de créatine
qu'en est il exactement
j'ai été confrontée trois fois oui c'est
vrai à un juge d'instruction qui qui
avant même de poser des questions
étaient persuadés que
il y avait du dopage dans le football
qu'on utilise et le p o
donc c'est très difficile de faire face
à un tel personnage
la créatine aussi c'est vrai qu'elle est
utilisée elle autorisée dans ces pays
certains pays dans d'autres n'ont jamais
pris pendant une certaine période après
j'ai arrêté je pense pas que ce soit un
produit nocif même si certains
spécialistes le disent mais le dopage en
règle générale et je pense qu'il y en a
dans le sport dans le football j'ai pas
été confronté parce que je pense
sincèrement je vois pas l'utilité
je crois pas que le dopage est un
produit peu d'un
la joueur bidan de faire un super joueur
mais ça jamais fait tirer dans les
lucarnes je ne vois pas trop l'utilité
ça peut faire courir plus vite ça peut
être plus résistants mais il ya le
ballon et le ballon c'est une fille et
il faut savoir le diriger donc que des
matchs très souvent même temps la
répétition évidemment qu'on a des aides
au niveau pharmaceutiques pour aider à
récupérer mais ce juge là est partie du
principe moi c'est ce qui m'a dit enfin
d'interrogatoire il me dit je voudrais
arriver à faire une loi que le
footballeur ci prend un produit une
vitamine c peut importe où on est
enrhumé ou qui prend quelque chose la
semaine avant le match il ne puisse pas
jouer un match
ouais il y aurait plus beaucoup de
football à la télé ça va bien merci de
votre sincérité la question
quant aux idées les champs vous
confirmer c'est comme à la télé pas de
dopage dans le football